Yes.
Now,
I mean the,
at least,
at least he's a character like bigger than life character.
You would just flip flop and you don't care and your pants are hanging off just
to get on a flight to Boise.
Just come on.
Why Boise Boise,
I love boys.
I'm just,
what's the issue?
Because it's a shorter flight.
I didn't want it to be,
I was like,
you can't even get it together for a short flight.
You know,
it's disgusting.
And it was weird.
It is weird.
It's just come on ideas about footwear.
I judge people when I see them with Yeezys on,
yeah.
Including Jamie.
I have something right there.
No,
I don't know.
You gave me some,
I don't have exactly where she sat right here when you go there was like six
months ago,
right when he gave him to me in the box right there.
I've contemplated running in them,
running through like a cream and filming it because people love these things so
much.
But uh,
I don't want to run it on,
are they expensive?
Cause I like running and choose it are actually supposed to be running in.
Yeah,
they're expensive.
He's,
he gets it.
Look at him.
He's upset.
Jake,
Jamie's one generation younger than me.
So his like idea what these things are is different than mine.
I feel like they're mad at you for saying that right now.
Some people are,
some people think it's hilarious.
You would do that.
That would run with them.
I know they're mad at me,
but they're dominant.
We're mad at me for what I would do with a pair of sneakers.
You're a fucking idiot.
Right?
And you need to get your shit together.
It's nothing to worry about.
Thinking about sneakers too,
right?
Are you happy?
Are they just sitting here and there's fucking people think I'm joking.
What do they look like?
They're sitting here and this fucking box.
I'm not joking.
I mean I didn't plan this out there.
They're here.
The people who are into them are like,
oh my God,
you got him there and you're not.
You go home and you're not even for Austin.
He should be out flaws in man where
he's taunting me cause I mock his all the time.
It looked like some sneakers from the eighties some,
but it's like they look like the sneaker version of that Shitty Mustang from
no man,
the cool whole backend sticks out like this.
The heel has like a duck bill behind you.
It's so stupid.
It's so bizarre.
Yeah.
Look dumb that Kanye West has a large effect on humans.
Very interesting area.
Family feud.
They were on family feud.
Well,
I just heard Howard stern talking about,
I hope they ask them tough questions just to,
just to see the ballpark
is try it.
Try being a book and that house,
you will collect dust motherfucker.
We read,
I don't care.
It's broken up into chapters.
Read Shit.
I'll stay read tweets.